this video was made possible by
brilliant learn to think like a
scientist for 20% off by being one of
the first 500 people to sign up at the
link in the description nuclear energy
is one of the cleanest most efficient
and most available sources of power on
earth to generate one kilowatt hour of
energy the amount an American household
consumes in 48 minutes nuclear power
plants only emit 12 grams of carbon
dioxide enough to fill about 3 2 liter
soda bottles meanwhile to produce the
same amount of energy coal plants emit a
hundred and twenty grams of co2 about a
full bathtubs worth factoring in the
environmental cost of production nuclear
energy is cleaner than hydropower than
geothermal than solar than really any
energy source except wind but that
doesn't necessarily mean nuclear is the
long term solution for the world because
nuclear material is perhaps the most
poisonous substance on earth two times
in history have nuclear power plants
leaked significant amounts of radiation
in 1986 in Chernobyl Ukraine and in 2011
in Fukushima Japan
31 people died in Chernobyl with at
least a further 4,000 expected to
contract early lethal cancer due to
radiation Fukushima is better contained
with only two deaths both unrelated to
radiation and only 130 early cancer
deaths expected but additionally each
site still today has massive exclusion
zones where humans cannot live due to
ongoing radiation hundreds of thousands
of people were displaced from their
homes and will never be allowed to
return the economic damage of Chernobyl
is estimated at nearly 250 billion
dollars significantly more than the GDP
of Ukraine the Fukushima disaster
meanwhile having taken place in a much
more populated and developed area is
expected to set Japan back over 500
billion dollars a full 10% of their GDP
in addition uranium the elements most
commonly used in nuclear reactors is not
in limitless supply using present-day
extraction methods there's only about a
230 year supply of uranium
left many would say nuclear is only a
short-term solution to reduce carbon
emissions until truly sustainable energy
can become commonplace but the biggest
problem with nuclear energy is not the
risk of meltdown it's not the supply of
uranium it's this nuclear waste all
current commercial nuclear power plants
work through the process of nuclear
fission as a radioactive element decays
the individual atoms split into two but
when that happens the reaction also
releases energy there are plenty of
different designs of nuclear reactors
but in general they capture the released
energy by using it to heat up water into
steam which runs through turbines that
spin generators the nuclear element used
is typically uranium which after about
six to eight years of usage in a nuclear
power plant will have released enough of
its energy that it is no longer useful
in nuclear reactors but that doesn't
mean it's done emitting energy the fuel
rods will remain radioactive enough to
emit a lethal dose for tens or hundreds
of thousands of years past their removal
so the question is what do you do with
them the answer is simple put them
somewhere where they can stay
undisturbed isolated forever
but that's not all that easy in fact no
nuclear waste worldwide is currently in
what is considered long-term storage
every bit of nuclear waste in existence
is in temporary storage facilities to be
used until a long-term solution is built
most of that nuclear waste is stored in
pools of water water does a decently
good job of shielding radiation so this
is an inexpensive and easy way of
storing the rods usually these pools are
physically inside the nuclear power
plants
so when spent fuel is removed from the
reactor it's put directly into the water
and left there the radioactive material
since it's still emitting energy
continues to heat up the water but
cooling systems and pumps keep the water
below boiling temperature but to do that
the plant needs power if the power fails
and the backup generators fail the pumps
and cooling systems stop working so the
water heats up and can boil off the
water is what blocks the radiation so
without water the radiation just goes
right out into the environment
in fact exactly that happened at
Fukushima both a primary and backup
power sources failed so the pumps and
cooling systems for the spent fuel pools
couldn't run leaving the water to heat
up the situation was brought under
control before enough water had boiled
off to release significant amounts of
radiation into the environment but had
it not been thousands could have been
killed
once nuclear waste has cooled down in
storage pools for ten to twenty years it
typically is encased in casks these
concrete and steel containers block in
radiation but dissolution is far from
permanent it does not consider
earthquakes it cannot withstand tsunamis
and it would not work without humans
these casks require security and they
require maintenance without humans they
could easily be damaged or breached over
time and release radiation into the
environment modern humans have only
existed for about two hundred thousand
years so one can hardly be sure that the
species will survive for the millions of
years that the toxic nuclear waste will
continue to emit radiation what's more
one can hardly expect that the dominant
civilizations that have nuclear
technology today will continue to exist
for even thousands of years the Roman
Empire was once without a doubt the most
powerful civilization on earth scholars
even believe that it is the most
powerful civilization to have ever
existed on earth more powerful than the
u.s. than Europe than any modern
civilization but it fell and so too will
the West
therefore long-term nuclear waste
storage needs to last longer than any
political structure it needs to work
without the supervision of humans it
needs to be truly and unequivocally
permanent Finland is building just that
this region is largely devoid of natural
disasters it doesn't have our cakes it
doesn't see tsunamis it really doesn't
encounter any natural phenomenon that
could damage a nuclear waste storage
site especially if it's 1500 feet
underground beneath an island on the
Finnish Baltic Sea coast the country is
digging there building the very first
permanent nuclear waste storage facility
in the world in the stable bedrock 1500
feet below currently they're just
finishing their dig down then very soon
in 2020 they'll start filling the
facility with nuclear weight
they'll dig long tunnels with small
holes in which they'll place casks of
nuclear waste and backfill the tunnels
with clay to be left for an eternity
with this system
there's near zero risk of nuclear
material leaking out into the
groundwater and once it's filled in the
Year 2120 it can just be left forever
because the material will be so far down
and so difficult to get to
no human management will be necessary
once completed no security no
maintenance nothing which means it
should be truly secure but before
leaving it they do need to fight against
one thing human nature as curious beings
it's hard to combat a person's urge of
discovery if someone finds a mysterious
structure from thousands of years ago
it'd just be natural to want to open it
up and that's a problem for nuclear
waste sites we essentially did just that
with the pyramids in Egypt these
structures were built as the final
permanent resting places for the elites
of Egypt and we opened them up because
we were curious opening the nuclear
storage facilities would release
radiation into a future civilization so
we have to tell them to leave the site's
alone but that's easier said than done
the US Department of Energy commissioned
a study on how to communicate the danger
into the far future the key is to create
a message that conveys how uninteresting
how unimportant and how dangerous
nuclear waste is they settled on the
following text sending this message was
important to us we considered ourselves
to be a powerful culture this place is
not a place of honor no highly esteemed
deed is commemorated here nothing valued
is here what is here was dangerous and
repulsive to us this message is a
warning about danger the danger is in a
particular location it increases towards
the center the center of danger is here
of a particular size and shape and below
us the danger is still present in your
time as it was in ours
the danger is to the body and it can
kill the form of the danger is an
emanation of energy the danger is
unleashed
only if you substantially disturb this
place physically this place is best
shunned and left uninhabited the ideal
would be to translate a message like
this into every United Nations think
Arabic Chinese English French Russian
and Spanish there's a reasonable hope
that at least in the next couple
thousand years one of those languages
would be understood but in the scope of
hundreds of thousands of years there's
just little expectation that these
languages would survive there's not even
a reasonable expectation that humans
will survive so you need to convey the
same message without language what the
study suggests is to further push the
message by building a landscape that
conveys danger it could be a scene of
thorns or spikes or forbidding blocks to
say she that discovers curiosity it's
also suggested to add monoliths
explaining the history of the site
through pictographs also included would
be images like this engraved in stone
conveying that the substance has danger
that would be passed on to humans if
touched but the difficulty of this is
that it very well might not be humans
exploring earth 100,000 years from now
it could be a species that doesn't
recognize the likeness of what might be
a long extinct species what some have
suggested is to just let the sight be
forgotten to not mark it at all to just
seal it up and leave but having
something that significant disappear
isn't simple the site in Finland is
designed to not need security or
oversight but its current location is
very well documented in a potentially
irreversible way with books and brains
and the internet records of the site
might exist until at least the end of
human civilization to truly be forgotten
to truly be left as part of nature so
too must humans be forgotten if you want
to learn about clean energy or anything
else you should try brilliant they have
a fantastic course on solar energy
complete with approachable explanations
straightforward graphics and
thought-provoking puzzles I've really
been enjoying brilliant because their
courses do a great job of providing an
overview of complex topics in a way that
anyone can understand as a Wendover
productions viewer who enjoys learning
or is serious about science brilliant
interactive puzzles will help you
explore all kinds of interesting stuff
if you want to check them out head over
to brilliant org slash went over the
first 500 who do and sign up will
receive 20% off
I absolutely suggest that you give
brilliant a try because it's truly a
great website and doing so helps make
Wendover productions possible